dawn is with us in Dallas hi dawn
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up well first I need to say hi to my
YouTube crazies hasn't been the one
that's been trying to call all day
and I just wanted to get your opinion
about the path that I'm on I took
financial piece back in October
September October I'm baby step to
single mom 45 years old I have a three
year old son
Adreno retirement I have $100,000 in
debt cars being loaned some old medical
bills on taxes and I'm worried that it's
going to take too long for me to get out
of debt before I can start dating like
for retirement and college fun and all
that kind of stuff and based on my
calculations we're looking at five to
six years
say I'm a single mom and I have my only
my income what did you run out sixty
five thousand okay what's your career
field
I am an office manager for a medical
software company okay
how much do you owe on your car I'm
about 8,000 like 79 and some change how
much in back taxes and it'll be about
1,500 no more okay so what is most of
their student loans in my mr. look yeah
and I don't know I get much a child
support he pays half a day care and
that's it so it's just filling me in my
income okay well the way you projected
out five years is you projected that
nothing changes in your income or your
situation and so um you know we know
that life is a filmstrip not a snapshot
so we look and say you know probably on
average your incomes going up the
question is how much is it going to go
up and how much will that affect the
five years of turning it into three or
four but still at 50 years old give or
take you know 47 to 50 you're going to
start saving for retirement well that's
okay okay not it's not best
I mean I'd rather you've started when
you're 25 you would rather but you know
it's the hand that was dealt you and
it's what you're dealing with but you
really don't have the option to goof
around right I mean you've really got to
focus and keep chipping away because
what happens in a situation where you've
got this big a student loan debt and
this big a debt overall if you're not
careful it becomes so overwhelming it
feels hopeless and when you're hopeless
that gives you permission to do stupid
stuff okay what we learned in that when
I get hopeless it's like well it doesn't
matter anyway I'm going to go out to eat
it doesn't matter anyway I'm going to go
buy this item it doesn't matter anyway
I'm going on that weekend trip none of
which you can afford to do right and
because it does matter and every little
thing adds up here and you really do win
against something like this that there's
a concept that we see I always equated
metaphorically to hydrostatic pressure
which is kind of a ridiculous thing but
if water gets behind something I've been
around the real estate business water
gets behind a wall on your house like
the basement wall it'll push the whole
freaking house over because water is
relentless you know and that's what
hydrostatic pressure is water building
up against something it is relentless
eventually it will push it down whatever
it is and that's what you're doing here
you've got this huge Hoover Dam in front
of you but you and your life become the
relentless water with that constant
pressure against it and then what
happens is this thing that seems
insurmountable all of a sudden you get
where you can see it I can do this thing
I act I'm going to be able to and it
starts to get within reach and the more
it gets within reach the more energized
you get but you do keep up that
hydrostatic pressure death by a thousand
cuts you are not going to win by one big
umph
you're going to win by lots of little
tick tick tick tick tick tick just keep
picking at it and and suddenly it
springs a leak and then suddenly it all
caves in and the water wins and you're
the water in our in our story line here
so on
that this constant pressure against
something that big and always think
about you know something like the you're
probably not old enough to remember
Reagan looking at Gorbachev and saying
mr. Gorbachev tear this wall down
well that wall had been between free
Germany and communist Germany for
decades and it seemed insurmountable
anybody tried to cross that wall was
shot and killed nobody could take that
wall down and it seemed like it suddenly
that the Communists decided to take the
wall down suddenly but it really wasn't
suddenly there was a constant pressure
by freedom against that until it finally
fell it wasn't politics it wasn't Ronald
Reagan Ronald Reagan was there when the
when you did the cymbal crash the
crescendo the Shh and that's where you
it's where you are you're the constant
pressure and then it's going to seem to
outsiders looking in that your debt
suddenly fell but you and I are going to
know that for 48 months without letting
up
you leaned on this thing you pushed on
this thing you were not going to quit
you are not going to be denied and
that's that's the thing that's how you
look at it hey thanks for the call we
appreciate you joining us you're going
to win you call me back if you get
scared or tired as you're fighting I'll
kill I'll walk with you hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
down
[Music]